in the world of language nerdery there's
perhaps no greater language nerd than
the con Lang language nerd Khan Lang is
short for constructed language and it
refers to languages that don't evolve
from the organic forces of culture but
rather were deliberately designed by one
or more individuals Khan Langer spend
years decades even lifetimes building
their languages and let me tell you
there is a lot more to it than just
making up a few or a few thousand words
according to the language construction
kit by Mark rosenfelder you have to
decide on phonetics morphology
orthography syntax and semantics just
for starters it also helps to be
familiar with lots of existing languages
if English is your only frame of
reference you'll be missing out on the
wonderful variety of sounds and systems
that humans have generated will your
language be agglutinative like Turkish
will it have subject object verb
structure like Japanese or maybe
ergative absolutive alignment like
Basque I told you this was going to get
nerdy
it may not seem like there's much
practical application for conlangs in
the real world but the history of
invented languages deepens our
understanding of language in general
it's potential its limitations and its
beauty I'm Dr Erica brazovsky and this
is other words
[Music]
other words
perhaps the most famous conlanger is
J.R.R Tolkien linguist and author of The
Lord of the Rings creating his fictional
Elvish languages
tolkien's true passion and priority
[Music]
foreign he was inspired by the beauty of
Finnish and Welsh and because real
languages evolved with time Tolkien
wanted his to as well this required
writing a detailed history and mythology
of the people who spoke them which ended
up becoming one of the most beloved
fiction franchises of all time and
basically created an entire genre of
popular entertainment this is more or
less the opposite of how that other
super nerdy fictional language came
about in the early 1980s a linguist
named Mark okrent was hired by Paramount
Pictures to devise a Klingon language
for the upcoming third film in the Star
Trek franchise up to that point the only
Klingon that had ever been heard were a
few lines after James Dewan came up with
while filming Star Trek the motion
picture
okron figured that since this was an
alien race he ought to choose features
that are very rare in human languages
like an odd object verb subject sentence
structure and a collection of phonemes
that are difficult to pronounce
individually let alone in quick
succession
foreign
also wanted the language to match the
coarse warlike culture of the people who
speak it so Klingon has many different
synonyms for fighting but no word for
hello the closest you can get is
which means what do you want
linguist David J Peterson took a similar
task when inventing Dothraki for the
Game of Thrones TV show it has 14
different ways to say horse but none for
thank you when helping James Cameron
develop the navi language for Avatar
linguist Paul fromer wanted it to be
relatively easy for the actors to
pronounce though he did include some
ejective phonemes voiceless consonants
produced with a contracted glottis like
ah
similar to those found in real world
languages like Mayan and Chechen Navi
does not require specifying gender in
its pronouns though it does offer two
forms of we we as in me and you and we
as in me and someone else that way you
always know exactly who's invited
clearly it takes a lot of work to make a
fictional language sound real but does
anyone actually speak them
not really of all the fictional
languages Klingon has the greatest
number of truly conversion speakers and
they could probably all fit onto one
plus
fictional languages like Klingon quanya
and Navi were invented mainly for
artistic and aesthetic purposes however
some language inventors were much more
ambitious they believed their Creations
were actually improvements over natural
languages that they could unlock human
potential and better the world
in the 17th century many scholars became
preoccupied with the Tower of Babel
problem according to the Bible God
cursed Humanity with many different
languages as punishment for building a
really tall tower the inability to
communicate these Scholars believed was
still holding civilization back and they
thought they could fix it by trying to
outdo God once again with a man-made
universal language the most famous
attempt of the time was by Bishop John
Wilkins who didn't like that words were
just arbitrary representations that had
to be memorized he believed that in a
perfect universal language the very
essence of a concept should be encoded
into the word itself with each letter
representing a hierarchy of
classifications for example a dog was
called Zita because it was a
domesticated land-dwelling carnivore
with an oblong head and Clause this
barely makes sense when describing
animals but Wilkins tried to classify
everything and I mean everything the
result is hundreds and hundreds of pages
of complex hierarchies May many of which
are pretty subjective for example
witchcraft is categorized under judicial
relations subheading capital crimes as
we explained in a previous video but
Wilkins didn't understand is that words
being arbitrary memorizations is not a
bug it's a feature it allows us to share
a vast mental dictionary that can be
effortlessly and instantly accessed we
don't need to describe a dog every time
we say it because we all already agree
on what a dog is
despite the failure of Wilkins life's
work the dream of a universal language
was resurrected in the late 19th century
when a small book called lingvo
internation was self-published by
someone calling himself Dr Esperanto
which means one who hopes it was a
guidebook for an international auxiliary
language a kind of backup language which
could be used by people from different
nations to communicate with each other
the true author was L.L zaminhoff a
Jewish ophthalmologist and amateur
linguist who grew up in a diverse area
of Poland like Wilkins zamanhof believed
that a universal oxlang could benefit
the human race but unlike Wilkins he
wanted to be easy to learn so he barred
familiar morphemes from existing
Indo-European languages like ham for man
and am for love in a very simple
predictable grammar
anyone with a couple of years of Spanish
under their belt should be capable of
decoding simple sentences like Kyo estas
via Nomo today Esperanto is the biggest
real world success story of all invented
languages there are hundreds of
thousands of fluent speakers including
several thousand Rays on it however it
never quite became a universal auxiliary
language perhaps due to the rise and
power of Britain and the United States
after World War II which cemented
english's role as a de facto lingufranca
but International diplomacy isn't the
only problem that conlangers have tried
to fix in the early 20th century a
linguist named Benjamin Wharf
hypothesized that the language you speak
limits your perceptions and cognition
like maybe having more words for colors
would actually enable you to see more
colors and maybe Klingons would be nicer
if they did have a word for hello some
even worried that Humanity's Reliance on
language prevented us from understanding
the true nature of the universe words
might be Plato's Shadows on the cave
wall
sociologist James Cook Brown wanted to
test the wharf hypothesis by inventing a
language that could Empower its speakers
to shed all their preconceptions and
think with perfect logic log land short
for a logical language is an example of
an engineered language one designed for
theoretical or experimental purposes its
grammar was based on first order Logic
the kind used in mathematics and
computer science which makes literal
translations sound more like equations
than sentences loglin was designed to be
totally unambiguous there can only be
one possible way to interpret a sentence
you can't just say that Romeo and Juliet
fell in love you must specify whether
they fell in love with each other or
individually with other people whether
they just happen to be in love while
falling or whether they landed in a pile
of love all the contextual Clues and
assumptions that lubricate our everyday
conversations are forbidden this makes
logland so difficult that it's unlikely
anyone speaks it fluently enough to
actually test The Wharf hypothesis
making things even more complicated a
disagreement between Brown and his
closest supporters created a rift in the
log Lane Community and a competing
alternate version called Lodge band
disagreement is a common theme in
conlangs even Esperanto had its schisms
with offshoots like reformed Esperanto
Edo Mundo Linko and romaniso no matter
how engineered a language is no matter
how controlling its creator it will
inevitably evolve to fit the needs of
the people who use it like the dinosaurs
in Jurassic Park language
finds a way conlangs may not have a
stellar historical success rate but they
do a great job of revealing how we feel
about language we can be entranced by
its beauty fascinated by its variety but
also frustrated with its limitations and
even afraid of its influence over our
thoughts
perhaps there will never be a truly
Universal artificial language but as
long as people yearn for new ways to
express themselves they will always push
at the boundaries of what language is
we've only scratched the surface of
constructed languages there are over 500
of them out there by one count if you
want to know more you can check out
Erica okron's book in the land of
invented languages
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign